And you could do the intuition thing which is you can look at this
and arrive at the point that there's no correlation and this is correct.
It's a little bit tricky, but you can see x go up from 3 to 4 and y shrinks.
Then it goes from 4 to 5--the opposite happens to y, and it increases by the same amount.
That means in our data set, it will look as follows--up, down and up, and then they happens
we already saw the best fit is the horizontal line, and the horizontal line just means
x and y are completely independent for this best linear fit.
Knowing x does nothing about y and knowing y does nothing about x,
and this kind of independence leads to a coefficient of 0.
Let's check it. What's the field over here? It's 0. It's 0 because -1+ 0+1=0,
That's interesting even though this field over here ends up to be 6, 1²+2²+1².
Zero of anything gives us a 0 at the end. So let's look at one final case.